[Music]
everyone my name is Jessie and today I
am with testing for famous celebrity
brownie recipes to see which one is
actually the best I'll be testing
recipes from with Gordon Ramsay Guy
Fieri Ayesha curry and posh spice
herself Victoria Beckham I measure out
all the ingredients as the recipe states
to level the playing field and I gotten
three brownie lovers in the office to
test them out and blind taste up some
did someone say brownie so which
celebrity has the best brownie recipe
let's get baking
up first is Gordon Ramsay he starts by
combining butter and sugar in a large
bowl and beating that with electric
mixer until it's nice and fluffy that
gets melted chocolate and beats it again
to combine it's kind of chunky so I gave
it a few stirs that add salt vanilla
extract cocoa powder and flour and mix
that all up until smooth add some eggs
mix it again and took it's nice and
fudgy add some milk if it needs to be
thinned out a little bit and then you're
gonna add a shit-ton of dried cherries
this is seriously a la dried cherries
pour that into a lined baking tin smooth
it out so it bakes nice and even
and pop it in the up once baked put some
edible glitter pop rocks and sprinkles
on top because you know regular brownies
aren't enough this is like a child's
imagination of space it looks like I got
kids brownie oh don't cry I have to dad
just bite into oh my god zap pop rocks
oh that's really weird there's something
else in here this is cherry instead of
chocolate that's good cherries and
brownies are a 100 percent yes the fruit
it's pretty good just leave the cherries
on the side otherwise pretty freakin
delicious guy BRE starts by combining
cut rhubarb water and sugar in a large
pot and cooking that down until it turns
into a nice combo meanwhile you're gonna
combine chili powder salt flour cinnamon
and baking powder and sift that also
there is no chunks in it set that aside
then combine butter white sugar and beat
that together with electric beaters
until it's nice and fluffy
add some eggs and continue beating it
and took it's even fluffier add rum
vanilla extract and then bring back that
combo you made and add melted chocolate
to it stir it together it'll look kind
of weird but add it to the eggs and fold
that in until it's nice and smooth add
some flour and fold it again until it's
nice buggy and looks like a nice batter
add chocolate and walnuts and stir it
once more bring in a pan that you lined
with parchment paper put it in there and
pop it in the oven there you have it
brownies I'll take you straight to
flavortown the cross on the top is
beautiful I can really figure out my
life just looking at this crust there's
some kind of like cinnamon in it it
doesn't really taste like a brownie and
it doesn't have the texture of a brownie
it's more of like a cake you can hear
how sticky and like moist this brownie
is just asleep
up next is Ayesha curry with her or shot
of brownies she starts by combining
butter and chocolate chips and a double
boiler so it gets nice and melted take
that off the heat add white sugar brown
sugar give that a stir and add four eggs
add salt cinnamon flour stir that up
again to looks nice and fudgy then add
slivered almonds and fold that in
pour it into prepared pan smooth it out
and pop in that as it's cooking get some
rice milk reducing pour it into a bowl
add rum cinnamon give it a stir and add
a shit-ton a powdered sugar to it so it
turns into a nice glossy glaze take your
brownies out pour that glaze over and
smooth it out no harder than a few hours
and it's good to go
this looks like a brownie with lots of
makeup gorgeous well I like this not
your classic brownie but you still get
all the elements of a brownie in it I'm
very confused because this tastes
amazing it just doesn't taste like a
brownie I really like whatever is on top
it's like reminds me of like an apple
crumble I can't decide I'm sorry this is
pretty good I wish she had some kind of
crunch to it but as is beautiful thumbs
up for this one Victoria Beckham starts
by combining sugar cocoa powder and
melted butter in a bowl and stir it all
together and vanilla extract for eggs
and give that a good stir until it's
nice and fudgy add some baking powder
salt flour give it another good stir and
the batter is it posh keeps it nice and
simple
bring your pan in pour it in spread it
out so it bakes nice and evenly and pop
it in the oven now your bacon Like
Beckham this looks like the brownie I
know if you asked me to make a brownie
like this is what I would make this is
not very crunchy it's just like fun it's
definitely a little drier whoever made
this are you on a diet what's up
I'm missing my butt if I'm missing my
chunks like chocolate it's not chocolate
enough so which live has the best
brownies let's find out this is what you
guys have all been waiting for the best
celebrity brownie is number one I never
would have thought to put cherries in a
brownie and it tasted really good
because there's like chocolate and fruit
as a mixture is always great ah Gordon
Ramsay affords out of these four
brownies I think my favorite is number
three it had that those elements of a
classic brownie it was gooey the flavors
developed within it oh I like that my
favorite it's definitely number two the
combination between soft and crunch was
so amazing
and I'm always looking forward to that
totally see this being his creation
Kevin oh we need you to be the
tiebreaker who me I really don't like
this one I like that one a lot
I thought I liked it Bruce I can't
number two is definitely my favorite I'm
a new fan of Guy Fieri hi guys so there
you have it
Guy Fieri has the best friends
[Music]
which celebrities would you like us to
try next hit us up in the comments